Salut ! On a tendance à croire que,
de notre pensée nous vient des mots.
Et en fait, c'est l'inverse.
C'est les mots qui fabriquent notre pensée.
En toute logique, si on arrive à changer le sens des mots, alors on peut influencer la pensée d'une personne.
Aujourd'hui je vous parle...
de l'influence par les mots !
[Musique du Générique]
[Imitant Doc de "Retour vers le futur"]
Marty, remonte dans la Delorean !
[Tentant d'imiter Marty]
C'est vous le doc doc !
La voix de mon Marty ressemblait
plus à celle de Porcinet !
Ce sont de petits cadeaux que j'ai eu à la fin du spectacle à Toulouse ! Merci !!!
La tournée du spectacle continue
puisque ce mois-ci je serai
en Occitanie : à Montauban,
et puis ce mois-ci je serai aussi
en PACA à Senas,
et dans le grand Est
à Mulhouse...
et à la Vidéocity à Paris.
Comme d'habitude, les dates de tournée
sont dans la description.
Comme j'étais en train de vous dire
au tout début de la vidéo:
On pense avec des mots.
Ces mots déterminent notre manière de penser.
Si on n’avait pas les mots, notre pensée serait un peu confuse, un peu nébuleuse, un peu sensitive...
C’est le fait d’avoir des mis mots
qui a formé une pensée construite.
Mais les mots influent donc
directement sur la pensée.
[Ironique] C’est bien bien clair toutça!
Si on change un petit peu les mots,
on peut changer notre manière de penser.
C'est ce qu'ont compris
les grandes instances depuis longtemps :
Mettre en place des concepts positifs pour éviter aux gens de penser négativement.
[En anglais] Manipulation !
Je vais vous donner
un exemple très concret:
On parle de Youtubeur ou d'influenceur;
de vidéaste et d'influenceur.
Un vidéaste ou un Youtubeur,
c'est un mot qui représente directement
un savoir-faire, une action.
Il a fait quelque chose,
donc il est ce quelque chose.
Il fait des vidéos : c'est un vidéaste.
Il met du contenu sur Youtube :
c'est un Youtubeur.
Un influenceur,
ça a un autre sens.
Il existe avec une communauté et il va être capable de l'influencer pour dire ce que je veux moi.
Donc je vais pouvoir exploiter sa position.
Et pourtant vous avez vu qu'on parlait
de la même personne.
Donc suivant le terme qu'on définit:
on change notre pensée.
Parce que là si je pense à untel
comme étant influenceur,
je ne vais pas avoir les mêmes pensées qui me viennent que si je pense à untel en tant que vidéaste.
C'est aussi pour ça que je n'aime pas trop
qu'on m'appelle influenceur !
Durant la guerre du golfe il y avait ça.
On avait transformé le bombardement...
Le bombardement, c'était des bombes qui explosaient n'importe où et qui faisaient des ravages...
C'était devenu : des frappes chirurgicales.
Avec le mot chirurgical, on rattachait
des images de précision.
"On a tué exactement la personne qu'on voulait"...
C'étaient presque des snipers, les bombes.
Il y a une excellente vidéo de Franck Lepage que
je vous mettrai aussi dans la description,
où il explique la différence entre le terme "exploité"
et le terme "défavorisé".
Il y a une dizaine d'années, on disait qu'un ouvrier
était un exploité ; c'était l'appellation quoi, "un exploité".
Donc issu d'une exploitation
de la part de quelqu'un.
Et on a transformé ce mot,
petit à petit, en : "défavorisé".
Donc là c'était juste...
pas de chance.
C'est le hasard.
Dans la vie courante également,
vous devez faire attention aux mots que vous recevez
et aux mots que vous prononcez
pour voir si vous n'êtes pas manipulé, vous,
par la personne qui est en train
de vous parler directement ;
ou si vous n'êtes pas manipulé, vous, également
par quelque chose de plus gros que vous, qui vous a mis une nouvelle idée dans la tête.
Dans le monde de l'entreprise, avant,
il y avait le licenciement de masse !
Mais heureusement, c'est devenu
du "plan social"...
pour sauvegarder les emplois...
C'est plus pareil...
C'est ce qu'on appelle un euphémisme.
Les euphémismes...
mais, il y a aussi les oxymores !
On ne dit plus "récession"
depuis très longtemps !
Parce que récession on comprend...
Tu vois ?!
Non !
On dit la croissance négative !
Donc une oxymore, hein...
parce que ça ne va pas du tout ensemble le mot "croissance" et "négative" ;
et bah on dit ça aujourd'hui.
On dit qu'on est en période de
"croissance négative"...
donc ça monte...
mais à l'envers.
Confucius disait,
et Confucius c'était pas l'année
dernière qu'il disait ça...
Il disait  : "Si j'étais en charge de gouverner,  je commencerai par rétablir le sens des mots."
C'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on s'est aperçu
qu'on pouvait se faire manipuler
la pensée par le sens des mots.
Avant de faire cette vidéo,
je me suis amuser à analyser plein de choses
comme des mots tels que :
Suffrage Universel.
Si on prend le sens littéral des mots,
ce serait un suffrage universel si
on avait, réellement, nous-même choisi
les personnes pour qui on avait voté.
Mais, en fait, on a un choix
défini au départ,
on n'a pas fait ce choix là...
Il est vrai que c'est beaucoup en politique
que j'ai trouvé des exemples,
et dans le monde de l'entreprise aussi :
c'est pareil, avant, on disait plus
"Les salariés"...
On disait "les salariés", surtout dans les
start-up, dans les grosses boîtes,
on disait "les salariés",
aujourd'hui, on est tous devenus
"des collaborateurs".
Et oui, parce que le salarié,
en fait,
il reçoit un salaire pour
faire une tâche ;
Le collaborateur :
il vit pour le projet !
Il doit donner de son temps,
de son énergie,
il doit tout faire pour
que le projet réussisse !
Le mot "projet" est aussi beaucoup
utilisé, maintenant, dans les entreprises.
Parce qu'on est tous des collaborateurs
autour d'un projet...
Quand tu arrives à bannir un mot
du langage,
tu arrives aussi à bannir
des idées.
Donc, dans un one-to-one
ou, dans une surpopulation,
on peut faire en sorte de changer
les idées et les pensées...
Vous avez remarqué que,
depuis quelques années,
on ne parle plus du tout
d'échec scolaire ;
C'est terminé.
Ce mot n'existe plus.
On appelle ça :
je trouve qu'ils ont été champions
là-dessus...
"Une réussite différée"
Mais c'est pas que
la réussite est différée,
c'est qu'il a foiré son année !
Bon, ben ce n'est pas grave,
trouvons une solution
analysons les causes,
prenons, chacun, nos responsabilités
sur l'échec scolaire
à ce moment là.
Et bien, aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus
besoin de trouver les causes
et de prendre des responsabilités
puisque ce n'est pas un échec !
C'est une réussite différée !
C'est juste... un petit peu de retard...
Pour l'agro-alimentaire,
consciemment ou inconsciemment,
je ne sais pas du tout,
je n'arrive pas à trouver des sources
à quel moment ça c'est fait...
mais pareil: en préparant cette vidéo,
je me suis rendu compte que
on ne nomme que très peu
les animaux qu'on consomme...
Alors, je ne l'avais jamais
conscientisé,
je l'ai conscientisé là,
en préparant tout ça.
Moi, quand je vais à la ferme,
je vois des poules dans le jardin,
je trouve les petites poules
mignones, etc...
Par contre, je mange du poulet.
Ce n'est pas le même animal,
à la base ?
Mais en disant "poulet",
on enlève l'image de cette petite poule.
De la même manière,
on élève des vaches,
mais on mange du boeuf...
Et si tu vas au salon de l'agriculture,
tu verras des cochons,
alors que tu manges du porc...
On a réussi, comme çà,
à changer, dans notre esprit,
l'image qu'on avait des animaux
qu'on consomme
pour ne pas se sentir coupable.
C'est très malin tout çà
et ça doit être une des premières fois
qu'en préparant une vidéo
moi aussi je prends conscience
au-delà de ce que je voulais dire au départ.
Si vous aussi, là, maintenant,
ça vous fait un petit truc dans la tête,
de... "Ah put***, c'est ouf !"
mettez un petit like
pour le signifier.
Parce que moi, ça m'a fait une émotion
un peu étrange
de m'apercevoir que c'était encore
plus fréquent que ce que je pensais.
J'ai lu quelque chose de très intéressant
d'un linguiste Suisse
qui s'appelle Saussure,
et autant vous dire que Saussure...
c'est une pointure...
Dans son cours de linguistique générale,
Saussure nous dit :
Psychologiquement, abstraction faite
de son expression par les mots,
notre pensée n'est qu'une masse
amorphe et indistincte.
Philosophes et linguistes se sont toujours
accordés à reconnaître que
sans le recours des signes,
nous serions incapables de distinguer
deux idées d'une façon claire et constante.
Et rien n'est distinct avant
l'apparition de la langue.
Vous voyez que ce n'est pas
une idée reçue,
que les linguistes attestent,
en fait, que
les pensées proviennent des mots.
Il y a un passage d'un de mes
livres préférés
qui est "De l'autre côté du miroir"
de Lewis Carroll,
Dumpty dit à Alice :
"C'est de la gloire pour toi."
"Je ne comprends ce que tu veux dire
par Gloire", répondit Alice.
Dumpty sourit d'un air dédaigneux,
"Naturellement que tu ne le sais pas,
tant que je ne te le dis pas.
Je voulais dire : c'est un argument
décisif pour toi."
"Mais Gloire ne signifie pas
Argument décisif !" objecta Alice.
"Lorsque j'utilise un mot"
déclara Dumpty, avec gravité,
"Il signifie exactement ce que
j'ai décidé qu'il signifierait,
ni plus, ni moins."
"Mais le problème,"
dit Alice,
"c'est de savoir si tu peux faire en sorte
que les mots signifient des choses différentes."
"Le problème", dit Dumpty,
"est de savoir qui commande,
c'est tout."
C'est en relisant ce passage que
je vous ai mis ce petit truc sur les réseaux sociaux
ce matin, si vous me suivez sur Facebook,
Twitter ou Instagram,
j'ai mis une petite phrase
un peu rigolote.
Et si vous ne me suivez pas,
les liens sont dans la description.
C'est encore une fois de garder
son esprit critique vis-à-vis de tout ça.
La prochaine vidéo, je ne sais pas si
je vais la sortir là, dans la semaine
ou samedi...
Et je ne sais pas si ce sera les résultats
de l'expérience mentale
qu'on avait faite,
il y a quelques semaines...
Vous avez été extrêmement
nombreux à participer,
je mets beaucoup de temps
à traiter toutes les données
parce qu'il y en a, une...
une... une foule !
Il y aura encore une vidéo
cette semaine,
mais il y en aura peut-être
encore deux !
Je ne peux pas vous dire quand est-ce
qu'elles sortent exactement.
Si vous êtes abonnés,
cliquez sur la petite cloche
qu'il y a à côté du "abonnez vous"
vous savez où est cette cloche.
Comme ça, vous aurez la notification
et vous ne la raterez pas.
Et si vous avez des exemples,
vous aussi,
de manipulation par les mots
que vous aimeriez m'expliquer,
mettez les moi dans les commentaires,
je vais lire tout ça avec plaisir,
je prendrai le temps de vous répondre
demain à tout ça,
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on ait
encore d'autres exemples.
Peut-être, d'autres exemples
de la vie courante...
J'ai utilisé surtout ceux des industriels,
du système scolaire,
du système politique...
Mais je suis sûr que vous avez
plein d'exemples comme ça,
en oxymore, en euphémisme
ou autre à me donner.
Comme d'habitude, n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner avant de partir,
à très bientôt !
Ciao !
[Musique du générique de fin]